a thrilling new teaser trailer for
upcoming Disney Plus series the
mandalorian has arrived and it gives us
our first look at Meghna wins mysterious
assassin character the 30-second clip
consists mostly a previously seen
footage including sweeping looks at the
outer rims landscapes and the
Mandalorians weaponry and clothes as
well as a few of the creatures ships
people and battles he'll face at one
point in the new teaser trailer the
Mandalorian appears before a group of
aliens and humans among them is Carl
Weathers Greek cargo whom we know works
with the Mandalorian and heads up a
bounty hunter guild the trailer also
sees the return of several scout
troopers on speeder bikes
plus the Taika Waititi voiced IG 11
rapidly spinning and unleashing a burst
of plasma energy shots around it the
crowning moments in the new Mandalorian
teaser trailer however is a brief but
punchy exchange that sees agents of
shield actress Ming no-win deliver a
single goosebumps inducing line to the
titular character your name will be
legendary
it's a funny nod to the fan favorite
bill and ask Boba Fett's who wore almost
identical armor to the new Disney Plus
series character but as showrunner Jon
Favreau has clarified that wasn't an
actual Mandalorian and Pedro Pascal's
character is up to this point not much
has been revealed about Ming no wins
character fennec Shan in an interview
with Vanity Fair when revealed several
details about her role when described
the gun-toting mercenary a similar to
Han Solo and that she starts with no
beliefs in any causes but her own
according to when we got her inspiration
really from the name the idea of a
fennec fox came to mind I just loved the
whole image with the name Ben excisional
concept design apparently gave her a
more disheveled look but she appears in
the new Mandalorian trailer as much more
put together that's due to when who had
a hand in shaping her character's
appearance to be more fitting of the Fox
imagery when said at first the idea was
maybe just have her hair be loose
unkempt kind of thing and I thought well
she's going to be wearing a helmet then
she's this stealth assassin how great
would it be if her hair has a bit of the
fennec fox architecture to it so the
hairstylist came up with this great
radiance system that just gives an idea
of these triangular points like her ears
due to the darkness of the shot in the
trailer in which Vanek appears you can't
quite see the more intricate elements of
fennecs hairstyle but when revealed that
her braids will be threaded with orange
as a call back to her characters Fox
inspiration expect her outfits to
feature these color elements as well
according to when the designer Joseph
poro came up with this amazing outfit
that I fell in love with right away it's
black but then there's the fennec orange
punch to it so that's kind of like her
brand I guess while we've got a peak at
Phoenix and now fans will have to wait a
bit to see her make her first appearance
on the mandalorian when confirm that her
character and the mandalorian aren't
slated to cross paths until halfway
through the first season on the upside
the new trailer from the mandalorian did
manage to deliver more about another
previously teased character voiced by
Nick Nolte anak not named quill who will
Kanye
anyway past previews have offered silent
glimpses of the alien writing a blur a
two legged creature that looks sort of
like a fish dinosaur hybrid but this is
the first time we've heard this guy talk
the mandalorian the first live-action
Star Wars TV show also stars Giancarlo
Esposito as interstellar administrator
Mach Gideon and Gina Carano as former
rebel shock trooper Cara dune plus
Verner Hertzog as an imperial agent bill
burr as a bounty hunter and Julia Jones
as a character presently known only as
O'Meara the Disney Plus series will
premiere on November 12 check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]